kip let's talk about that middle-class
famous store baby uh i think you're
talking about buffalo pittsburgh and
detroit that's right we're gonna be
coming to buffalo jumping on the table
detroit we're gonna be hanging out with
eminem and pittsburgh gonna do a little
coal mining
guys get your tickets it's a great way
to introduce your boys or your gals to
the show
squad grab a cruise send it out in a
group text it's uh me and foley each co
headline t-bones on the show we're
bringing our boy tom cassidy and we
close it out with a little live ayg with
the crowd you've seen eclipse you know
what we're doing get those tickets the
links in the description do it welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage yep it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we found that they're
growth to be classy yeah just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at anthony's basement
where it's always summer
because she's not really working right
now
she's in between jobs over there my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table this is a family episode we're
gonna be answering your questions just
the squad the homies the bozos t-bones
and the big head give it up for kj kevin
james ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes
as you know those numbers are true
they're cooking over there
and then obviously
uh my i
you know i don't want to speak for the
group but it's my personal favorite
website of all time xnxx
close second uh
you porn variety um
www.patreon.com
ru garbage you sign up you get i don't
know about a bajillion hours a lot of
stuff over there already on there fun
for the whole family you get [ __ ] you
know we're shooting disney and uh
three weeks that's gonna be up there
soon you got the roulette spin up there
you got the cribs videos you got the
down ashore video we just announced our
new goal the uh we're gonna go camping
boys are gonna get an old school rv go
camping a little family couple of beers
maybe a shotgun or two
we got it somebody's got to bring some
sidearm yeah i'm gonna need a sidearm so
there's some [ __ ] up there
uh yeah we're gonna have to figure it
all out i don't know this is how i don't
know plus you guys think it's gonna be
some leisure cruise it's not we're i'm
gonna take you out in the woods and show
you what it's like we're gonna pull back
the curtain a little bit on how things
are how things operate over here at ayg
we don't really iron out the details we
come up with a [ __ ]
pretty stupid idea and go that's it
we'll figure it out when we get there
like disney in july like disney in july
like a ten thousand dollar roulette spin
based on a thing from a tv show that we
were wrong about
a whole lot of dumb [ __ ] colombo played
blackjack yeah
good stuff though check it out we love
you we appreciate the love we appreciate
the support and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man the pride of the chicago
comedy scene recent transplant here in
queens he's got a new place new jean
shorts he's looking fresh and fit give
it up for toby mcmullen what's up dudes
what's up ebay thank you my shorts are
feeling good i'm glad you found shorts
that were also a t-shirt
yeah that's an odd that's an odd vap
that's like 80s weightlift power lifter
fabric you got on there i used to wear
those for my dad the russells oh yeah
dude sweatpants shorts are a bad luck
when they when they you know it's a bad
pair of shorts when the when the
drawstring is connected
hey dude you can't make a knot i didn't
figure that out until college i was
supposed to cut it uh-huh
i don't think you're not supposed to cut
it what do you tie it in a belly button
knot yeah i like you like you're showing
off your mid-drift
is it mid-rib or mid-drift mid-drift i
think it's mid-rib tokyo drift i know
that
all i know is rift it's mid-rift the
mid-rift of your body but doesn't
mid-rib also make sense you're showing
your rib the middle of your ribs drift
mid-rift ah you're both wrong what is it
mid-riff
oh we're throwing a t on that yeah the
region of the frame van halen what are
we talking about
i'm over here melting a couple of faces
hit me with the whammy bar kid
talk box
do you feel like i do
uh good [ __ ] um question for you i'm
listening cleaning the apartment we're
getting out of town for a couple of days
me and the bird there yeah taking patty
down a chair um
i was telling you were under on fights
on that trip
i told you i've had i have terrible
anxiety go just even thinking about
going to there was not listen i love my
family but there was never not love
you're starting to warm up to me
i got a handshake at christmas oh dude
like a divorced dad in court i love my
family
but i had to kill him
the dog kept looking at me
um but there was there was and it was
always
because of me and my brother
and they were just two people in a bad
situation you know [ __ ] trying to try
to trying to make good with their
[ __ ] rotten kids we would call it
like your parents are [ __ ] dr phil
and oprah by the way okay
those two were as crazy as he's like
taking a vacation with the westies you
don't know who's getting stabbed
everybody's got a knife
rob's behind your mom with a [ __ ]
piano wire in the car that's what i was
gonna say
yeah it's everything yeah anybody can
get it like more [ __ ] laurie's
waiting for my dad coming [ __ ]
mid-atlantic city expressway you're
coming back your whole family come here
this is crazy um so there's a lot of
anxiety in that uh just going down there
i can feel it i'm just waiting for a
divorce i'm not even married um
but i got delegated to uh i got to clean
the house like we had the cat sitter
coming you got to clean your apartment
yeah you know how that is it's like you
live a certain way and then when someone
you put on airs dude even if my my wife
has like friends in the building she'll
be like oh [ __ ] you know
megan's coming up i'm like right now i'm
like i [ __ ] sure over the couch i got
a swiffer going which is the real
separation between garbage and then just
a dirt bag family cause i've had friends
where you don't care oh my the milk's
[ __ ] in the garage they don't know
what's going on yeah that's tough when
you show up and you're like you knew i
was you knew you were having people yeah
yeah and they're moving like laundry
baskets and stuff out of the way yeah
you want sweepers out here let me clear
you see nope
there's a dead cat there sorry i do that
with my car if i know people are going
to be in my car or you explain i am
sorry it's a mess sure but that gets to
a yeah of course but i have a thing now
where i gotta because we've been driving
the [ __ ] we've been driving hans all
over [ __ ] creation down the shore
down to my parents over here over there
covered in dog hair
and he's in mid shed right now this is
when they [ __ ] they shed two times a
year i've learned um to really what is
the lizard midship no they're like they
i didn't know i never had this kind of
dog is always coming off of them no they
have two times a year it's like in the
spring i guess they shed for the
whatever and then in the f i don't i
don't even know him someone just said he
oh he's in his [ __ ] seasonal shed i
was like yeah google that really steve
irwin
get out of my car i'm gonna get a
[ __ ] stingray
zip it move it along i'm trying to catch
a bernie
um throw you in the croc tank so it's
all it's like crazy it's bad and that's
and dog hair is embarrassing and i it's
so bad i can't this is what the
the kia did a i did a pretty good job no
bernie's in the kia no real eating
whatever but i mean like he's thrown up
back there a couple of times he's eaten
at a couple is he drinking what the [ __ ]
puke out the window on the ground one
paw on the ground
stare at the horizon
i'm so embarrassed i can't even take my
car my current car i can't take to
a car wash it's like i gotta do some
really there's that much if they open up
the back door they're gonna be like what
like this is bad dude you kill a llama
but then i also did another very trashy
thing of i i don't use the car that much
i was parked under a train like i said
it was like really i think i've
mentioned
it looks like you pulled it out of a
[ __ ] swamp like it's like bird [ __ ]
there's the things from the leaves the
rain and then that you get rats in there
if you leave them too wait it's got a
whole rat in my kia you know that that
happened that happened to a friend of
ours because he had food in there he was
storing his he was go our friend would
go to costco buy a bunch of food and
then leave the food in the car thinking
it's like storage and the [ __ ] rats
were like yo sweet dude he drove us down
to my parents and he wanted he had to
get like an oil change or something so
we took him to our guy [ __ ] dude
opened the hood he was [ __ ] puking
his guts out it was just covered in rat
[ __ ]
yeah no i don't have any anything in
there but
i was at my mom's recently and my car
was so dirty and i just like i couldn't
so i just i did a real trashy it was a
real trash thing i just sprayed it with
the hose
like no soap no nothing just to like
clear off some of the pockets inside no
on the outside
which makes it worse i don't know if you
know that you guys got a squeegee from
the gas station doing the inside you got
to dry the car otherwise it looks where
i look
i'm driving
the flagrant patreon
i was so happy you didn't see my car
i you would have never have let me dude
it literally looks like it was
underwater not too long ago the amount
of [ __ ] trouble down at alligator alley
jack klump yeah it's real bad real bad
have you ever had to clean your
apartment before a drug dealer came over
that's a tough one yeah that's if you
don't even i mean i don't know i don't
partake in the devil's lettuce
i get high on life
and james
if you're gonna get side eyes from the
guy with the bag that's no good it's a
tough luck yeah but there's also
there's a process or a procedure to that
if we're talking about the same thing
you want to have the apartment clean
before the night's festivities
you know what i mean
i don't please explain
to your mom who's watching
more i'm more of a satan's bacon bits
kind of guy
talking black tar baby black car
spike it up
that's a ben jerry's flavor right black
tar
imagine they came out with that
you gotta inject it
but what um i'm trying to take a little
more responsibility at the house uh you
know the ladies working and all that
kind of stuff um so i said i'll clean
the apartment huge mistake um you don't
realize how dirty your apartment is
until you start cleaning it and that's
when you start really pushing the goal
posts there's the thing too when you're
cleaning
it gets dirtier like when you prop or
clean
you move stuff there's a pile of trash
now like everything's kind of hidden
it's livable what's weird is if i walked
into your apartment okay never get the
invite but
let's say it was clean i wouldn't think
anything of it but if you walk through
it you would see like the little the you
know the things on the car the corners
and the spaghetti sauce on the thing you
would you don't normally see that kind
of stuff but when it's in your apartment
you do like right behind where the trash
can is it looks like somebody blew chef
boyardee's brains that's real bad you
ever pull that bad boy out too oh yikes
you don't want to know what's going on
back there it's like cultures or red
light districts but you're just keeping
it bad that too and also to around uh i
noticed it real bad around our sink
because like you're washing the things
are flying little water splashing and
then you're like oh i'm done then you
leave and you come back and you're like
once you're cleaning like everything
you're like yeah it's like there's like
[ __ ] an inch of grease on that oh
dude the [ __ ] the the stove the
grease it's like
was the kentucky fried chicken
what are you doing more the crown fried
chicken guys by itself there's my
procedure with the bathroom we lightly
talked about this i think the other day
uh where i used a toilet brush kind of
[ __ ] to get everything i sprayed
clorox on the floor but
you go through [ __ ] 25 000 paper
towels to do that you shouldn't be doing
with paper towels i'm not sure what i do
is i take the old towel after i spray
everything down and scrub everything i
mean like everything the whole area
around the toilet the floor behind the
thing where the p splatters
and then i take an old towel or a towel
that's done
and i just [ __ ] like bath towel bath
towel okay i just take like the towel
that i've been using for the week or
whatever it was i'm gonna get a new
towel you trash that though or do you oh
you don't wash that and use it do you
he'd wash it in hot water
what's the difference about that that's
okay it's funny you mentioned this one
that's a no flop that's the second i'm
cleaning up pee and fecal matter i'm not
then using that i don't i mean you could
wash that you could give it to nasa for
them to [ __ ] wash it and i'm that's
still not this thing the mars yeah no
this time i did it was you took me off
guard that you said that which that's
also a no-no too i'm not allowed to just
throw out i don't have that kind of
clearance over there just throwing out
towels
i'm gonna get called upstairs for that
that's like a billy mays infomercial
it's covered in piss it's covered in
[ __ ] and it's clean still
that's crazy use it for 12 more showers
also you better not be using the generic
stuff in the washing machine you need
something you need some heavy duty i'm
talking heavy bike detergent
take that brand name oxiclean dude oh
yeah yeah no like oxy jazz or whatever
i'm all oxyclean my mom has a stain
removal uh formula that works like a
charm you spread it's got like apple
cider vinegar this that that's it she
makes it at home in a spray bottle i
think there's gatorade in it too i'm not
100 sure it has a really great hangover
but yeah you put it in the sun it comes
right off but i did throw that one out
i threw that towel out yeah but normally
i would wrap that up and stick it in the
bottom of the thing uh-uh and then you
wash out with your clothes and stuff no
we separate the [ __ ] towels and the
sheets and the and the clothes cause all
my clothes i have to watch in ice cold
water don't need shrinkage
ice cold uh-huh i do yeah i do cold
called then i hang which i don't think
when you drop it off in the new york
city play in the new york city
laundromats that they do do it in cold
everything comes without dropping a
volcano dude they [ __ ]
dude they go how they give you the high
heat
high heat in the washington
drive if you toddler clothes back you're
like what the [ __ ] and i left the sheets
in the dryer too long on high heat and
i'm telling you they were smoking they
were [ __ ] so hot they smelled burnt
yeah do you have a drying rack in your
apartment or are you opening cabinets
and [ __ ] to hang your shirts on um
who's doing that what if you don't
you're hanging your shirts to dry
yeah you do uh-huh wait there's some
things you don't put in the dryer yeah i
just said that let's ask me another way
see if the answer changes
wait
so what shirt like would that go in the
dryer this one does because this is a
proven it can withstand its integrity
shout out to sal volcano by the way uh
this guy uses high quality merch over
here
sally we love you put one of those ayg
shirts in there
in the dishwasher it's over
you gotta [ __ ] wash that down with
the crick
get your washing stones with your
washcloths
um
yeah no i have uh
i have two different classifications of
black t-shirts that i
i'm a wacko you know i don't know
so i have two different classifications
of black teas that i use
um some were just around that i got
about 40 i would say black t-shirts
dude you have one t-shirt and you wear
it until it disintegrates got it on now
i'm big on that uh that new tree shirt
it looks like you have to fly i've read
the youtube comments they're aware as
well because it fits great
it fits great and some t-shirts [ __ ]
when you wash them they get softer and
they get looser and they get fantastic
and then some it's like you're putting
on a burlap sack sure what happened yeah
i don't dry so i hang i do i was a wreck
yeah i re of recent i was just doing
like a little wooden one you're talking
about it's plastic but yeah uh we had
that in our living room when i was
growing up i was like what the [ __ ] is
my mom always used it for her delegates
oh yeah
kevin stop playing everybody i was
always ready to wake up in the my mom
would wash stuff in the sink like that
with like wool lights oh yeah i remember
that patty would do that yeah so like
i'd come down to [ __ ] make a bowl of
special k and there's a bunch of panties
in the sink
i'm not panties i'm kidding
i'm clearly kidding songs
they were all songs bdsm type stuff uh
a couple of ballgames my you can't get
leather wet
what are you doing what's your first
goddamn problem
no just like there would be like a
sweater you're wrapping up a sandwich at
latex panties
sweaters or like blouses like that type
sure i just i used to play with my gi
joes on there that was a
rack yeah uh that was point two but i
just got a rack but for the longest time
i still the rack because i do wash a lot
of black tees a week so the rack can't
hold them all
so i'll do like over the doors or the
dresser or on a chair or something for
the last two if you do them over the
doors sometimes there's that thick layer
of lint on top of the door you don't
realize that i know i know you're
standing at the hose stand the gallagher
is getting laughed i know i know patty
does something she she does your mom do
this my mom washes her hair in the
kitchen sink whoa yeah no yeah washes
her hair
in the kitchen sink i'm sure she does
when she's in the shower i don't know
sometimes she just washes her hair it
makes me feel like i'm at the spa yeah
i turn the heat up real high
close all the windows smoke a couple of
menthol cigarettes open up some nail
polish
yeah she wants just like the four
seasons
she washes her hand in the sink because
you'll be downstairs yelling for what i
can't hear you i'm washing my hair
she's [ __ ]
it's all funny places like your kennel
in there until your ponytail gets caught
in the disposal yeah
we don't have a garbage disposal you're
crazy you don't have a garbage disposal
what the [ __ ] they don't trust that [ __ ]
sometimes you explain your house and it
sounds like it's from the 1800s
that weird that weird stove or oven
heater thing you got the coal stove we
used to have coal stove and now we have
a we have a wooden real house we're like
little house on the prairie vibes i
guess we have a wood pellet stove in
where the fireplace used to be
you put it in there i doubt it the coal
stove was tough um
yeah that's uh
yeah but now she has one thing they have
a dishwasher of course yeah she's got a
good dishwasher great dishwasher okay i
told you she almost [ __ ] it up because
she put like palmolive or something in
there oh yeah that was like a three week
process huh but
at night now
all you hear is ticking
she has timers
she has timers on everything the coffee
has a timer you know the coffee pot has
a timer inside of it she's using it
a [ __ ] style
external thing like i think there's a
timer plugged into the wall you plug it
in things are plugged into there and
when when you turn the tv off to go
upstairs about all you hear
it's like living in doc brown's house
it's [ __ ] wild
why didn't you just set it because she's
crazy
wait is that the turn nice cup of coffee
in the morning now that's to turn on at
seven o'clock of course yeah yeah we do
the same thing but we got i mean
actually no they moved to it apparently
that's on we go downstairs there's a
keurig
at the house and down the shore i got it
what i don't like to care i like the
plastic i understand but the immediacy
of having a cup of coffee within 12
seconds i like when it's percolating now
and you're getting ready for it i know
but when you're like jammed up you're
going somewhere or something you're like
i could use a cup of coffee
you got a cup of coffee immediate and
this is also too my mom's got a couple
of bucks starting to spend it a little
bit really keeps um she keeps the stock
of to go like
oh that's nice we did that for a little
with the lids yeah so it's like you you
know like you would be in like a [ __ ]
wawa or a 7-eleven you go you pull a
[ __ ] paddy just gank some out of wawa
we've had stacks because she was working
third shift that's pretty smart too i
guess yeah but yeah that's great they're
not gonna say nothing you throw a lid on
and [ __ ] you're out walking the dog
you gotta cup a joe two three seconds
maybe a little
oh something irish coffee now you're
talking my family's language
okay let's talk about the good people at
bespoke post box of awesome boxing
awesome is exactly what i was gonna say
and let me tell you something folks it
is fantastic it's the summer time you
want to come correct whether it's
grilling supplies whether it's uh
grooming supplies and gear camping gear
just cool guys stuff for a fraction of
the price do yourself a favor sign up
box of awesome yeah guys uh they were
nice enough to send us a bunch of stuff
i use it all the time it's like that
stuff when people come over to go what's
that you got this little thing you got a
cool shake you gotta get on that box
awesome yeah uh to get started just take
the quiz at box of awesome.com here and
so we'll help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month over uh across a ton of
different categories so you can always
keep it fresh moving and shaking each
box is valued at around seventy dollars
but you only pay a fraction of the price
plus with box of awesome you're
supporting small business ninety percent
of everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small look at that
small up and coming brand free to sign
up you can skip them you don't want
putin winning or cancel get 20 off your
first month uh monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com enter the
code garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
garbage know it now back
back to the show just like that
yeah use the towel spotlessly clean in
that bathroom now so you you don't have
you don't have the
like you said authority to just throw
out a towel
no i would have to run that by
really yeah i can't just throw out
towels
where's the towel oh
that might get in trouble yeah just say
i throw it out i put there
but what i put poop ball there was poop
and [ __ ] there's
just poop on everything in there i'm in
there uh-huh it's on the walls the tv
the whole night all right okay all right
okay all right let's get into some cues
here yeah gang so as you know when you
sign up for the old patreon over there
we will ask your garbage question on the
air look at that just the best way to do
it we do get a lot of submissions you
know via dms via [ __ ] twitter via
emails unless you toss us a heater
yeah if there's a heater i'll steal it
and pass it off as mine no kidding um
we'll try to we'll use them but patreon
obviously uh gets the first crack at it
uh cause they're the [ __ ] homies
how do you feel about your legs you feel
good about your legs how do you feel
about your toes they're so long you look
like you have french tips
that was all right it was all and he was
sitting on oh yeah yeah i had two intros
for how you came at me i'm not gonna lie
like psycho mad libs
french tips used to be hot back in the
day that was sexy that was like the
white line on it yeah a little tip yeah
i did it for a couple of years in high
school but no i kind of want to start
painting my fingernails
and my toenails you know what i'm really
into right now at harry styles
holy i don't think i could pick him out
of a lineup oh he's [ __ ] drop that
gorgeous i can tell you that he's got a
[ __ ] real summer hit out too called
as it was real big star that kid should
be a huge movie star i think he's doing
some marvel movies he's all right though
he's got a lot of like soul in his voice
he's a good kid yeah it's crazy likes to
play with the boundaries there
sexually yes really good and he pulls it
off too
that's good yeah good for him shout out
to harry styles
and that was the h foley celebrity
corner yeah yeah
it's tom cruise ain't bad either tell
you about that kid and that was hot goss
with hank holy [ __ ]
but you didn't hear that from me
tune in next week
i like that let's do a gossip column
that's the first that was not that
wasn't gossip that was you talking about
a guy i think you have a crush on i
could we get him in here that'd be nice
i don't know make some calls i have h in
here hanging out with him
seems to get down there with a kid
all right
let's get into find me attractive
will you paint my toenails for me
would you or anyone in your family [ __ ]
me
mg kelly does that [ __ ] too
machine gun kelly oh you know him as mg
man you are seven different kinds of
stupid
he does he paints his nails he's really
good all these hot kids are that's why
they're getting the babies
i'm over here in carpenter shorts
if we tried that we look like bosom
buddies
i look like mrs doubtfire
that might be a good idea that's pretty
good
where are we doing the new on ian's
podcast gang ian's got a new podcast
coming out go check it out
um
what were you saying
i'm all chubbed up over these so i can i
was creeping out of the closet that's
what we were doing hey we should do a
thing where i just come out of the
closet
we should do a thing where i say i'm
attracted to men
do the thing when i sleep with harry
styles huh
just for the show yeah
no i
it's the same thing i like these i like
what these young kids are i like that
these young kids are like really have
changed
because when i came up it was all gang
banging you know spinning rims and i
couldn't do that either big jerseys and
you know it was like thugs it was like
that was what was hot and young pop
culture was like these guys are in touch
with their feelings they're sensitive
everyone's included these kids went the
other way and they're [ __ ] they're
sexy yeah they're really got tattoos
everywhere couple of mamacitas that's
yeah mike probably does
all right that kid yeah i imagine he's
doing some numbers down here at the
office yeah yeah he said he's got a
couple set of steak knives in his house
with a quarter he's got he's got the
watch
um
he's getting flown to cabo
no time share for him um all right gang
so let's get into it this one is from
joshua never had a question read 10
homie here um thank you sir
what's trashier what's so this is a
summertime question what's trash here
having a real basketball hoop outside of
your above ground pool or the hoops made
for the pool
i would gotta say
the real size basketball net that's not
even a question you're not gonna be able
to shoot it he's too high
it'd be adjustable oh he would oh i
would assume also i don't think this guy
has an in-ground net with a glass
backboard that we're talking about this
is one of those you get the broomstick
out and lower well let me tell you this
no sand in that [ __ ] it's an
interesting question we have a [ __ ]
banger we have one it's a pool one that
has this huge tank that you fill up the
water together
it's real nice and it's on the edge it's
oh it's [ __ ] perfect and it's like
maybe like if this is the top of the
pool like the rims like here so it's
perfect yeah so you can dunk yeah when
you're [ __ ] when you're housing your
[ __ ] nieces and nephews
packing yourself [ __ ] backing your sick
dad your sick dad down in the lane
i was all bald
see this square belongs to me
but you're just hacking your mom yeah i
got five more to give
look she's she's got a bloody nose
so i could turn into larry bird 84.
but
as you know the foleys we like to do
things a little bit different you know
we got the above ground that's the way
to put it yeah the foleys do things
different we got the above ground and
ground tripwires
everywhere above grinding around
underground above ground but i could see
if you got the quick creed out dug a
hole
because those i don't yeah i don't hold
on we have a really good one we have a
really good water basketball but you
bought it like leslie's pools or what
you bought at a it's a it's for a pool
yes but most of those stink
you got to go heavy bite when you're
going you got to throw out you got to
shout a couple of beans to get them so i
can understand that if a guy had a
[ __ ] above ground pool and wanted to
[ __ ] throw the quikrete in and put
put the thing in there i would do it
just not too high i this is what i let
me tell you something is i'm sorry
i looked at those things i wanted to get
one from my dad so he could shoot hoops
but those things are like a grand what
to get one of the [ __ ] regular
basketball net they're expensive as [ __ ]
i'm sure i think this this is my take on
this from this gentleman here
he's got an above-ground pool that's
pretty much in an empty backyard maybe
like an old lawnmower that don't work or
something
and he's got one of those movable
basketball nets like on the wheels that
you fill with water sand in the driveway
and i'm assuming him and his dirtbag
crew are wheeling it just wheeling that
up to the [ __ ]
side of the shore yeah to play a little
bit i'll be doing alley-oops and stuff
yeah but that's i respect that
i would just argue
that's a trashy move to class it up a
little bit is you move it back when
you're done you don't just have the
basketball net in the backyard next to
the pool the whole season that's a tough
look
i'd probably leave it there i'm sure you
put the grill up next to the pool too
what are we doing kill three birds with
one stone
drag the fridge out of the garage we
used to do i think we mentioned i used
to do trampolines everybody had training
that was like the you know early 2000s
late 90s everybody i traveled
trampolining into the hoop into the pool
oh that's awesome yeah but it only lasts
for it's very
because you get wet and then you don't
have any [ __ ]
then you don't have any stance the next
time oh dude i almost [ __ ] came oh
that's asking for head on that on that
red brick that surrounds the in-ground
pool
another reason why i don't like [ __ ]
in-ground pools it's all kind of
affordable it's all concrete
it's very tough
sure and when you
you really
can spin a yarn on why you don't like
nice things sure
i don't like a million dollars you got
to pay taxes on that
who wants to do that there's another
jerk in the line i know um
but if you hit your head in an above
ground pool it's a lot less impactful
than hitting your head on a an in-ground
pool that's concrete i understand the
thing's on the door it's also three
times the size of it so you shouldn't
really be cracking your head on the
[ __ ] side of an english not mine
you've seen paddy's sure now i got a
question for you we really you know
obviously the uh above ground inground
has been a uh one of the impetus of this
podcast here that we do this program
let's just say
you make a couple of bucks right you're
building you're you're going out you're
somewhat argue we are
sure i think we had an argument this
morning about that
continue
um
and uh
what would i do would i dig up that pool
no no no no i'm saying you go you buy
you're buying your you know you have
enough cash where you go to a builder
and you're like hey i bought a i bought
a plot of land in bluebell or by your
parents whatever the dream is the dream
scenario okay plenty of space big house
you know
something like you know my mom's asks
like so you're like i'm gonna do like
your mom's house i'm gonna do a nice
house big backyard is she living with me
um
are you doing above ground or in ground
pool
you gotta do in-ground pool like money
i'm not i'm not saying money's not an
option but it's you know i honestly i
don't believe you i i know you don't
believe me you seldom do but you lie all
the time
that cool crisp feeling of getting in an
above ground pool it's something that
i've i'm used to since i was a kid i
loved it it would be banging however i'm
a big jacuzzi guy
you know that so you would have to have
an above ground drink you'd have to have
a hot tub that's no jacuzzi that i
wouldn't do if i could i would do a
custom
saltwater or infinity pool i would do it
no above ground yeah synchro yeah okay
and above ground salt water pool
infinity
you gotta be upside down for it to be
infinity but
you went on the roof right yeah yeah so
you would go in ground i would
that's the first time you've ever said
you would of course you're right your
wheels it on these diving boards sly you
said your brother has some kind of setup
like that he's got a waterfall or some
[ __ ] like that yeah get a custom job
uh-huh get our guy over there yeah have
him [ __ ] hook it up
shit's expensive though this is also how
i realized the uh how just i don't want
to say
the difference in lives that i lit like
my brother has this very nice house very
nice pool got a nice joint and uh the
other day it was like last weekend or
whatever was hot as [ __ ] in new york
[ __ ] you know 92 degrees and me and
my wife were like think we could go down
to danny's and use this pool i was like
that loses that is a real
just tell me what switch to turn on or
what
make sure you turn that pump off god
damn it you got towels dude what's the
deal yeah i was just like oh we're
living different lives yeah i'm like
coop talking there's plenty of pools
nice i got three air unit window units
going and one of them works
[ __ ] we're all hanging out in the
bathroom there's tons of nice pools in
new york that you can go to there's a
lot of nice pool this is another thing
that i want to talk about there is now a
service that i always used a couple
years ago when we were real hem doppling
tools for you looking for a good time
it's like an airbnb but for pools what
people rent their pools out patty get on
this
what are we doing
you're gonna start turning it out you're
leaving money on the table your dad's
out there looking at the girls
hey read the fine print ladies guys
gotta get a peek
say one of them hot dogs for the big guy
no huh we gotta get his lunch you can
use it's like airbnb for pools the name
of this company is so [ __ ] dumb what
is it swimply
swimply yes god and there's a really
there's a couple of cool ones in
somebody's house yeah they ran out their
pool for like i don't know give me a
price like 50 bucks an hour or something
oh that's making that up i don't know
200 bucks an hour man if i went to a
party who lives here
that guy looking at us we got it on
swimly the [ __ ] out of here yeah but i
think a lot of i don't think they're
home all that i think you can request
them not being home like whatever you
know i don't know request them to be
home
i want them eating dinner yeah i want
them looking out the bay window at me yo
these that's like cannonball
these are not legit dude no the ones in
new york city dude they're all above
ground pools and alleys yeah it's a fire
hydrant on 166th street
bring your own can
must agree to split the fine when the
fire department shows up that's trash
yeah but there's plenty of nice pools
there's a nice pool out there and a
story you can go to a lot of these
hotels
yeah i know i don't i don't want the i
don't
that to me that doesn't do it for me you
just want to cool off yeah i don't want
to like get on the [ __ ] subway to go
to a pool sneak in some hotel or
whatever
my friends would always get me to do
that yeah just act like you belong at
the standard room 902 i'm like i'm
wearing basketball shorts they know i
don't belong
did you go down to your brothers no no
did you make the call no no you have an
open invite right oh of course yeah no
but it was more of like it's so hot what
can we do
and i was like am i really going to go
just [ __ ] man you stink the kids are
running out to like practice and [ __ ]
like why is uncle kevin back there i
just know kev eating the chicken farm in
the hot dog
no eating a pool face down in the deep
end
looking rocks in your pocket like yeah
anthony soprano
jesus uh all right this one's from mike
ever mow the grass without picking the
dog [ __ ] up first oh [ __ ] yeah
you roll that dice i don't think it
usually goes horribly wrong what happens
i remember my dad used to make me pick
up the dog [ __ ] i'm in the yard and be
like this is counterintuitive this is
why we have a yard so the dog can [ __ ]
in the yard no what are you not having
me walking back there with a dust pan
and like a spackle knife to like [ __ ]
scoop spatulas scoop it in i [ __ ]
hated it when it's a fresh dump it's a
tough look when it's all a couple a
couple couple days old yeah i mean if
you catch them if you catch a fresh
heater yeah that could be that could
yeah but all in all if i had a backyard
i don't think i would pick it up you're
gonna blast her you're crazy of course
you would get that would
disintegrate no it doesn't that's the
point of having a yard man i'm not
picking it off you got to pick it up no
i don't know i don't have a yard you
can't have the kids running around back
there they're not kids your kids over
well that'd be weird i'm just having the
neighborhood kids over you're right in
your pool i'm on swimlane right in the
backyard uh yeah i don't know i mean i
guess i will i i just in my head it
doesn't make sense you got to pick up
the dog [ __ ]
not all of it it goes everywhere and it
leaves a huge patch if you're running
over with a tire plus then you got to
spray that [ __ ] off where you put it
back on the [ __ ] trailer i'm having a
landscaper in this [ __ ] so i gotta go
pick up the poop before the landscaper
that doesn't make you you're telling me
ever this is back to like the house ever
that doesn't make any you would have to
tell them but i assume they would charge
you for that
because they're turning for not picking
up my poop no no what if i pooped if you
said hey
just so you know i listen somebody said
[ __ ]
somebody took 37 shits in the backyard i
don't know who it was damn neighborhood
pooper
it would be the same as if you took an
m80 and stuck it into every turd in the
yard because it just explodes at all but
that's good for them that's good for the
great writing there's no way
it's dog shit's not a good fertilizer
because of what they eat i don't know
toby
i i you're a dog
i've i i don't know i don't my targeting
system is off because that seems wrong
to me and kippy also seems wrong i'm not
saying oh hold it back here i just it's
not cow is good for it manure i'm not
saying listen i'm not saying i'm right i
just find it insane that everybody that
has a backyard and a dog is picking up
the dog poop 100 they are i don't think
it smells it gets everywhere what do you
get i don't think so it disintegrates
hold on okay so you asked me a question
if i had a little money so you go damn
it is right dog poop no good for the
yard
bad fertilizer it's it's too high in
protein and it creates a very acidic i
only feed my dog grains there we go
doesn't matter not good for eating
either
nothing all right um so you're telling
me i don't know what i'm telling you if
you ever want to change it to make
myself look better so you buy a house
all right you buy a house i'm doing
pretty well i'll buy a house
which i found out there was a big deal
but you don't need 20 down
what do you need
you can have something called pmi or
something like that you buy insurance
take an antibiotic it says like you'll
they'll pay or something it's like an
extra fee
i don't like that
a cosigner no i could do a cosigner
there you go
don't call me yeah
i i just heard that i'll be in my above
ground pool i just heard the caps locks
on a thousand keyboards click as people
started screaming in the comments
what are you doing that's got real
reverse mortgage vibes to it no
apparently listen i gotta talk to if if
anybody knows a mortgage you got no
hold on so you buy this house whatever
however you get the money pmi
so 20 years
in 80 years i can afford a house it's
just you screaming in a bank no pmi like
sir we will not give you money i googled
it
talk to google is he here
you're telling me you have the dog up
there you're just gonna let the dog [ __ ]
in the backyard and you're never gonna
clean it up that's i gotta be honest
with you i've never thought about it but
i don't in my head that that's my
argument i've never thought about it so
it seems like who cleaned up the dog
[ __ ] in your yard i just told you i
would so there you go yeah my dad's also
a little crazy
to me i'm going this seems nuts he's not
denying that he's pooping in the grass
but he's on the right path you can't
just have dog [ __ ] in the backyard i
would have how long's dog [ __ ] stay it's
not like it's staying months it's like
microplastics here no you're gonna be
nuts
you're not generational uh-uh jenna get
out of here i'm telling you my dog's
poop his dog's dog's food
oh wait hold on you have to cut the
rings and find out how old it is
yeah dude you can't be doing that you
gotta [ __ ] clean the dog [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] average time for dog pieces to
decompose is nine weeks all right i'm
cleaning up the nine weeks
holy [ __ ] yeah holy dog [ __ ] that's the
whole summer well dog is it okay okay
here it is
uh
we have a little pen in the back where
she makes her bit where she does her
business i've seen this
pen it's it's not a pen it is a pen no
you've never been there there's an
upside down kayak in there what are you
talking about that's the pool filter we
shot a whole video there yet yeah we got
it we plugged it into the beginning of
the episode she usually dumps on the
deck anyway it's a space that you call a
panel she doesn't have to go back there
it's an extra area filled with sand and
a walkway
and lights
no this is not a proper picture of your
painting champagne he's painting it like
they constructed it that way we did
construct it that way that's the dog pen
i'll get patty on the phone right now
she'll look like they're all you're all
liars you're all right through your
teeth yeah because the last time you
brought it up let's talk to you for a
second before what's the play here you
called it a dog just go with it the dog
run yeah [ __ ] all over it's barely a dog
if it's anything and how you bumped it
down to pen yeah
can't have [ __ ] in the yard okay i
didn't i don't i listen i've never had a
dog where i my own dog and in my own
yard so good question though yeah great
question
um
this is from jim 420 first time long
time is it garbage to get fired from a
family business for failing a drug test
jesus
where's the money
i know right how about a kid down and
out where are you going to go whose
couch you're going to sleep
what the [ __ ] yeah that's pretty [ __ ]
up they fire you i would doubt this is
the this is my take of this question
it's like
he was probably a bit of a fuck-up and
he was like i'll hire to get back on
your feet but no [ __ ] drugs play off
the pills any [ __ ] you know
pop devils lettuce couple of two tree
[ __ ] tombstones
a couple school buses you know how it
goes it's a wednesday night starts
pissing hot yeah you know you're out
damn who fails a drug test by the way
by the biggest idiots i'm not assuming
dude if your family is also your boss
and they're giving you drug tests
they're trying to catch like they're not
going like hey don't forget drug test
it's not it's not corporate they're like
ufc fighters they just show up at 6am
yeah it's like usada or whatever
yeah they wake you up out of a cold
sleep
[ __ ] piss
you're sitting at breakfast with a bowl
of raisin bran all of a sudden your
mom's under there grabbing at your nuts
milk milk she's milking you
never see those videos me either
continue
what's milking you
what
in pornography
um the butthole no well no there's these
that's what you're into no stop dude
anytime i mention something you go
that's what your guy likes utter porn
imagine a massage table a lash tape with
a hole in it but it's not for your face
it's not for your face it's for the it's
for your member put your wiener yeah and
what do they do underneath there they i
don't i mean do i have to have to
explain what they how they cal they came
up with the name milking
um
okay
yeah drug yeah that's i would assume
that's not his first drug test he's
failed back to the milking
i don't give a [ __ ] about this dirt bag
nah it's [ __ ] up i wonder what they
got him for i will say this with drug i
don't think it was adderall
too much potassium
buddy you're low on iron
he could pass out at any second
um
that stuff usually moves through your
body pretty quick weed's the only thing
that really sticks around yeah i think
pills have me up a little oh they do
yeah i know that i know i know the good
stuff comes also it could be a hair test
those things they they got you guys
working for mi6 they got you dead the
right oh they're sure if they're doing
that they are looking this is more of a
parenting drug test rather than an
employer drug test i view okay this is
more of a family being like hey chad get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] together jesus christ
uh one to four days depending on what
you're taking pill yeah wow
i remember going to pick up a buddy
he's probably dead now uh
i don't think i don't think he made it
out of the [ __ ] i don't think he made
it out of the early aughts um
he he was on probation and we were young
and i was like 16 he was on probation
and we're like oh you hang he's like
yeah come pick me up go pick him up he
walks out with a 24 pack of water on his
shoulder i was like just got the call
they're coming in the morning i'm like
so he was just hanging just [ __ ]
there was a t they sold it like gnc or
something g and c had the t you can buy
p online you can buy the fake wee-wees
you heat it up the microwave i mean
somebody just wrote it not too long ago
movies that they heated up at a 7-eleven
microwave like right next to the [ __ ]
because a lot of times you go to the
place to pee
it's boiling hot
what i got a fever come on corona
holy [ __ ]
uh this one's from the real sam yam
shout out shout out to the yams and the
kantis first time long time ten dollar
home i love how everybody all the ted
there's a lot of ten dollar homie pride
yeah at the live shows yo ten dollar
homie buy that as they're walking away
or walking up ten dollar homie much
appreciated [ __ ] love it love it have
you ever frequented a bar where the
water supply wasn't connected to the
urinal so the bartender kept filling
them up with ice throughout the night is
that where they put the ice in there i
guess yeah i never thought of it but
yeah that makes sense i thought it was
there's just a drain and no water so the
pea melts the ice
so it didn't go everywhere i guess i
mean i probably originally in the old
school bars there wasn't a water
connection over there so they just used
the ice no it's for the smell the smell
the ice freezes the molecules that
create the piss smell there you go
[ __ ] johnny on the spot this week his
kid's all right oh do you have new
computer
the crazy part is i'm high
i need to figure this out for later dude
go get a cut of his hair we're going to
test him what if he got fired from a
podcast for being high
five he failed a drug test he didn't
have enough drugs in his system
i was smoking weed with you
unfortunately we detect no percocet in
your blood for that reason we're gonna
have to let you which means you're a
[ __ ]
we can't have no narcs on the squad you
know what i mean
you pull that [ __ ] on the street
our company ethos is a good time
um
this one this is the one i chuckled
about because it took me a minute and i
fully don't understand
what
how this i don't understand the scenario
that leads to this but it's a funny
thought
this is from stormy was your first time
flying a return flight
you drove there and flew i guess i don't
know which means
that's not that's got real rehab vibes
that's a rehab i don't know somebody
drove you there to sweat it out for a
couple hours
and then when you were all cleaned up
you got on it you got on the plane flew
back yeah
either was a money thing of we'll fly i
don't know there's but it's not great
yes i would say it's you drove somewhere
with somebody else and then you flew
back and
i'll be honest with you
the second time i was on an airplane i
did that because i drove to north
carolina to move there uh-huh and then
when i left i didn't have a car anymore
so i flew back i smoked that
hey you tested positive for a forward
yeah i flew back that's a that's a
little different that's like a move but
i get i guess but the return i didn't
sell the car i know but i'm saying a
return flight more of a trade a return
flight doesn't imply a move
you know what i mean a return flight
implies
i went somewhere with the intention of
coming back
soon
you see what i'm saying what what's
going on what's crazy is before you said
that story i was gonna say
explain it again
a return you didn't bot you when you
went to north carolina you didn't book a
return flight you moved to north
carolina and then flew home yeah things
didn't go great no but you were flying
home that wasn't necessarily a return
flight okay see what i'm saying like the
way i read it is this guy was going
drove to disney and then flew home i
don't think they probably were going to
wally world or whatever
the only classy way i could see that
going down is i had a buddy who got paid
a boatload of money to drive this sick
cadillac cross country a lot of people
do that i know that i know that that's a
good gig yeah good gig that's trashy
that's a good gig yeah you got a nice
get a top you get a vacation and a free
flight this [ __ ] idiot posted a
picture of him on a cliff in utah
drinking whiskey shooting a gun off the
cliff next to the car he was driving
leave the car there
that reminds me i had a kid who like
tried a buddy of mine uh he had a lot of
[ __ ] hair brain skin like you know to
make money and he started he convinced
somebody like a small business like a
[ __ ] sandwich shop or something to
give them like 300 bucks
to like do with their social media or
whatever this was like you know 15 years
ago
and he posted a picture on facebook
of that's how long ago it was i was like
yo shout out to the haters like i'm out
here grinding but i posted a picture of
the check with like the name the bank
account number the rounding number the
branch for 300 bucks and i'm like dude i
highly doubt your [ __ ] first client
wants their bank account information on
facebook scott's all my bad dude my bad
you're right you're right i'm like whoo
that's a tough look
immediately fails hey what's up
everybody i'm great at facebook here's
all their personal information i would
freak out i don't anybody know my
routine number no round
number i don't even know what it is
rowdy numbers are fine it's your
both of them could jam you up a little
bit yeah right everybody has it depends
on where like if you're a
you know chase bank in new york
everybody has the same rowdy number oh
okay it's just the location of the bank
huh
well there you go zero two one zero zero
zero
you know your routing number no chase is
routing number i know my rounding number
as well i used to do watch the man with
anxiety right there you know the routing
number i just had to type it so many
times zero two
don't tell anybody it's everybody what
are you joking you can google new york
city toby cut that i don't want people
knowing the bank that i might go though
kippy i was in i was in line in a
grocery store they had to type in a
number for a vegetable 40 30. go
cucumbers
pickles
stop 40 30. hold on you could you could
use deductive reasoning to figure that
out toby what what fruit would where
what vegetable would toby be getting i
wasn't getting it
squash kind of guy i think uh more of a
dino nugget man i don't think he would
ever buy a vegetable was the last time
you bought a vegetable ah 1986
born in
89. i don't 40 30.
it's common because the tomatoes
no
it could be i know what it is can i get
green peppers ah not green peppers wait
wait
ah we're looking for radishes
who the [ __ ] buying rabbits who knows
radishes yeah that's why that's what the
test was for
you hit me with a [ __ ] red seedless
grape they were selling rats 88 what do
you want i think they were selling
radishes at an acme in bucks county in
the early 90s are you kidding me
get a guy locked up for something like
that i remember taking that produce
that's tommy talk having so much on like
thinking my life was on the line bro he
would hold up he had a taken test yeah
he would hold up like what's this and
you had to write the code a comb [ __ ]
idiot propeller
good stuff yeah someone on patreon also
suggested that i take my driving test
without doing any prior research
and we want to film that so if you've
got a driving school that we can shoot
at that's not going to be an ayg there's
too much liability him behind the wheel
he kills somebody i'm not you know
you couldn't go to a driving school you
have to you have to just have your
permit you have to just go to the
without studying or anything oh you
gotta have your permit first they don't
have a driver's license
25 or whatever 18 in a lot of states 21
and some connecticut's the only one that
after 21 makes you get a permit i think
we should do that that would be great
he just goes and wins it you just make
you could figure it out you know how to
turn left and turn right right i've
driven a car yeah there you go i think
he would do okay
plus i played
this is not under the ayg banana i'll
sponsor emma
banana
honey
i got produce on the brain
4011 40 11 40 red onion red onion
sound like tom brady red onion cucumber
[ __ ] idiot
whose car you gonna use
big red the dog hair mobile paddies i
don't think so you have to get approval
for that plus she'd have to wet her beak
on the patreon that month
she don't play ball
time is money moving on
or if you have a private dirt track i
can race on before i get my license
that's the dream
sure that sounds like a toby industries
uh yeah you're not taking [ __ ] you're
not taking the [ __ ] explorer on a
[ __ ] dirt track get you a mini bike
or something
and a cousin sister to watch it
um all right let's see here this one's
from omar long time first time fellas is
it garbage if your parents send you to
the old country for college because it's
cheaper that's what i want to do what's
the old country wherever they're from
clearly is that probably europe oh my
god
college in europe is like
three thousand dollars for the even like
oxford or the sorbol uh oxford's
probably a little different uh or it
might be the same but i don't i mean i
don't know the greeds uh yeah it's very
just who gets it
i would assume i don't know um but yeah
like i i think my kids my wife was in
ireland my wife's college was like three
thousand dollars like for every like
four to four years damn yeah pretty
crazy no football team though send the
kids over there they have sports in
college over there
uh i don't know it's not as like
commercialized there's there's she's she
i was actually just talking about this
she was saying it is because there's
more
they're more branding of like come to
yeah
[ __ ]
uh average price in europe is uh 7 300
bucks per year and in the us it's 25
racks yeah
it's a lot of money damn dates i wasted
a couple of bucks on college
poor bastards i told him i didn't want
to go i still owe a couple of bucks i
paid a lot off but i still owe a couple
of bucks it's probably like i think it's
600 bucks i owe to the federal
government come get it out of my cold
dead patreon hands
who's that sally jones or what's she
called no
who's the brother sally mae
what's her deal she sold she then passed
me off the navian the navient passed me
off to someone else i got dude i was
getting passed around like a loose joint
i've seen those navian envelopes yikes
uh-huh send it certified or it never
happened i'm all yeah i'm all pretty
squared off yeah i moved
my mailman i think he's on the
collection agencies and [ __ ] people
like that must be so jammed up who the
[ __ ] answers a call that they don't know
their number oh yeah no [ __ ] out of here
take a hike
uh you still little college loans nah
sorry you're there for like a week right
yeah baby one semester that's all i
needed there you go
i got everything i need i
try to learn how to finger pop
keep it moving
i'm more of a private sector kind of guy
all right let's do one more thing get up
out of her
let's see here sorry i'm all over the
place all right this one's from dr
jasper shits and giggles okay first time
long my cardiologist believe it or not
sorry that's not what i want to do uh
ah doc sorry about that yeah well let's
see we can just so we'll do two what's
the trashiest knockoff article of
clothing or product you've ever owned
example payless adidas with the four
stripes
we were never really a knockoff
family or company or you know we never
really did that
knockoff stuff
the most embarrassing one one of the
most embarrassing thing was i i said i
had the nash skateboard and went to a
skate shop and was like what's up and
they were like i had an escape i had a
nash skateboard that was the first
skateboard i got more of a toy rather
than a knob yeah it was on the bottom it
said locals only it's real poser [ __ ]
real trucks are like that thick yeah
they're typically plastic brutal um
we we were more uh off brand when it
came to food in the house the fristed
flakes the toastums instead of the
[ __ ] pop-tarts we've covered that
but for a while when i was a kid
um
there was
uh not like i think it was life is the
beach hats
they were these little like hawaiian
hats they look like little bikers hats
like what like a cyclist would wear
and like you know you'd put your thing
up kids were wearing them but it was one
specific brand that was popping it was
life's the beach but there was a
shitload of knock-off ones yeah and you
had that yeah and also too jams remember
jams the shorts they were like hawaiian
shorts not really they were popular
and um
my mom wouldn't let me get them but in
homek that year oh this is bad this is
real bad and homeek that year get a pair
of jams i made a pair of jams
and i had to wear them i was forced to
wear them
to school it's a tough look and i made
them they were horrible
it was like the gordon girl trousers
seemed like quite the same one leg was
longer than the other it was a bad look
yeah yeah we were big on the store brand
like we were a super fresh family yeah
america's choice
america's choice for everything that
wasn't a big brand name if that makes
sense sure like we would do like
america's choice for like all the [ __ ]
but like chips pretzels you [ __ ] had
to come correct or i'd send her right
back
what was the line your parents would use
for that my parents had the stock line
of you're just paying for the packaging
that was big um
yeah probably that that's all you're
paying for the marketing
that like how do you think they keep the
lights on over there like it was like
very like that was a big thing i like
going to a casino like why do you think
they're in big bright lights because
they always take your money and they do
shout out to bailey's bastards
i found that out the hard way yeah i
believe that but now i've learned the
name brand is always better
name brand is better there's a reason
they're the name brand it really is
there might be like a close
i might find a salad dressing yeah like
there might be something that does
eighty percent of the name bring like oh
this is pretty good for a store brand
but you're qualifying it you're going
this is good for a store brand what my
mom told us or generic when i was a kid
well first no we're not getting that
too expensive shut up get in the cart
get in the cart do my thing
have my grapes keep it moving but
we were told that um
it's the same thing
that yeah that's what poor people say
they like coco puffs has to give the
store the same one the same product so
they could get the shelf space i found
that was not true no you're just made no
different cardboard box factory
that's cereal next to that
oh man yeah that's cereal [ __ ] the
bag of cereal
yeah we never that was our dude walk
into somebody's house with that that was
our red flag yeah can't sleep over got
to go
um all right this one's this one's from
f millie uh freedoms or something i live
near state fairgrounds and was wondering
could bragging it's trash to charge
people to park in your yard during said
fair we make a little cash on the side
for doing this
valet is extra i [ __ ] i respect i
respect it you know
yeah i i highly doubt they're probably
if you're the only ones in the
neighborhood doing it it's
probably a tough look at the you know
cars every block party yeah but like
that's awesome i assume everybody's kind
of doing it sure i've went to like a
game somewhere in a city
like i'm sure it was like la or
something at like the staples center
dodger stadium and they were like parker
you know park here park here and the
guy's like yeah leave your keys in case
i'm like dude you're just some guy on
the [ __ ] street giving you the keys
leave your keys get the [ __ ] out of here
dude cubs games yeah everybody i i get i
get i do it at cubs games oh big but who
has houses like who has people have
garages yeah sounds like a wonder what
do you get like two tree cars yeah some
businesses will do it too like uh clark
street dog their whole their whole park
they have a parking lot that's never
used except for dubs games damn and they
pile them out oh yeah wow what are the
cubs what is the cubs parking whoever is
doing that think of that
they don't have parking oh really it's a
stadium in the middle of the goddamn
city damn and there's no parking lot
over there nothing jesus christ dogs he
just told you
spot the big good for clark bugs but we
gotta ramp it up hold on i say it's
trash but i respect it yeah of course
it's not
i think the way it would be really
trashy is if you were the only like if
your neighbors were like what the [ __ ]
this guy's got cars all over the [ __ ]
but i'm assuming everybody that's
probably like a way for everybody to
make a couple of bucks i'm in baby
sure slush fund gang we love you love
yous we'll be back next week we're going
to have some new dates coming up on the
road late summer early fall it's going
to be a fun time yes um couple of new
t-shirts over there on that bonfire dot
com okay okay
sure is uh other than that can't thank
you enough we love you and we'll see you
next week